[Music]
like yesterday i would like to start by
giving you an update on our efforts to
address the crisis unleashed by the
belarusian regime
we continue to work very closely with
the airline sector to prevent the
trafficking and smuggling of people to
the buddha region in belarus
vice president sukinas and commissioner
volian and their teams have been in
touch with international aviation
organizations such as the arab air
carriers organization and
iata yata
contracts have also been established
with a number of individual airlines
and all airlines contacted have strongly
condemned any form of human trafficking
and have indicated their full commitment
to fight against it
these contacts are already showing fruit
to give you some examples iraqi airlines
has confirmed that it will not resume
flights to minsk
and turkish airlines will also suspend
sales of one-way tickets to minsk from
turkey
the turkish authorities will also
prevent belarus airline bellavia from
using the middle east network of turkish
airlines thus preventing it from flying
migrants to minsk
via istanbul
the european commission is as we have
already explained
exploring closely
sanctions including black listing
against airlines that do not cooperate
on this matter and are complicit in
trafficking
furthermore as you know vice president
eskina started yesterday his outreach to
countries of origin and
transit he was yesterday in the
united arab emirates and is today in
lebanon
there the vice president is meeting the
president
of the republic the prime minister and
the speaker of the parliament as well as
the ministers of foreign affairs and
of interior please note that uh very
shortly um he will be holding a press
point directly from lebanon you can
follow it live on europe by satellite
plus
also continuing our contacts with
partners in the region a commissioner
johansson will travel on monday to egypt
to participate in a high-level dialogue
on migration the current situation will
feature prominently in her talks in
egypt
furthermore we are following very
closely the humanitarian situation
at the border and we were very glad to
see
that iom and the unhcr were granted
access yesterday to the crossing point
in belarus where about 2 000 migrants
have been trapped since eight of
november
likewise i'd like to inform you that we
are in contact with the international
federation of red cross and uh rest
creston red crescent societies to
discuss potential ways of supporting
them in their invaluable health that
they can provide and are providing to
the people stranded at the border
all these aspects will also be discussed
uh and taken forward by the ministers
of foreign affairs when they meet
for the foreign affairs council
on monday under the presidency of hrvp
boreh
finally we stand ready ready to support
additionally with additional means our
member states concerned uh by the
situation as discussed in this press
room several times we are already
providing extensive
support for the management of our
external borders and for your
convenience we have published a fact
sheet summarizing the types of support
and the extent of such support
financially that we provide to the
member states you can find the link to
this fact sheet in today's daily
news please
like president policeman
londy the president of underlying
pronouns on this school video conference
lord you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and as the last point allow me to
highlight that a special echo finland
budget meeting is taking place today to
prepare the conciliatory committee that
we'll discuss later with the parliament
the adoption of the 2022 budget
commissioner han will participate in
both meetings representing the
commission the press arrangements will
be determined later in the afternoon so
we just ask you to keep
an eye on the details that will be
announced by our colleagues in the
council and in parliament
and finally before giving you the floor
for your questions let me remind you
that vice president schechterwicz is in
london today uh meeting with david frost
he will hold a press point from london
at about 15 45 brussels time
to brief on the talks you will be able
to follow it of course on europe by
satellite like always that's all for our
announcements today and now over for
your questions please
thank you donna um
just wondering if you could kind of give
us some insight on to what you believe
to be a
build-up of russian troops on the
ukrainian border
um
it was a believer topic of conversation
between president bundle and anthony
blinken when she was in
washington this week or still is in
washington i don't know
just wondering um did you kind of share
the assessment of the americans that has
appeared that an invasion could be
imminent
and what are you doing about this thank
you
thank you very much for your question
joe
allow me to recall that indeed a
president van der lyon met president
biden
on wednesday in washington they had a
wide-ranging
discussion about pressing international
issues they
discussed about the situation at the
belarus border but they also discussed
quite extensively about the situation
in ukraine you have seen the readouts
that we provided including the one from
the white house as well as ours and we
both refer to the fact to the fact that
ukraine was uh evoked
and that we both expressed our full
support for the territorial integrity of
ukraine this is all i can tell you about
what was said in that meeting
for details about our observations of
the situation in ukraine
i invited peter to join me
thank you of course the european union
is a direct neighbor of ukraine and as
such is watching the situation there and
around very very closely this was also
discussed already in april by the
foreign ministers when they had
dedicated discussion about russia's
military buildup at the ukrainian
borders and in and around the illegally
annexed crimea and since then we have
been as the european union looking into
ways how to enhance ukraine's resilience
and of course we continued to to watch
and we continue to watch the situation
and the information we gathered so far
is rather worrying
and we are also discussing and
exchanging with partners like-minded
partners transatlantic partners such as
united states but also united kingdom
and others
to see how the situation develops and of
course in light of further developments
we are open to look at further steps as
necessary together with these partners i
was mentioning
thank you very much joe you have a
follow-up question
thank you
is it your assessment that in recent
days
the build-up is suggesting
a
russian aggression rather than just a
standard kind of military training
exercise which we know
moscow and the kremlin carry out quite
regularly thank you
well when it comes to standard military
exercise there are certain rules and
procedures to be followed such as uh
informing on time uh the partners about
this so this is something that was not
that was not followed earlier this year
and that's why as i said there was a
dedicated discussion by the foreign
ministers already back then when the
military built up was really very
concerning on ukraine's borders and
since then we are watching the situation
we are assessing the situation and we
are exchanging information also with the
partners uh across the ocean and with
other like-minded partners and
there will be another discussion by the
foreign ministers which is scheduled for
next monday so this is also an
opportunity to to maybe see if steps
needs to be taken for the ministers to
to consider whether they would they
would go in this direction as i said as
i said the information we gathered so
far also with the partners is rather
concerning
thank you very much i will invite you to
raise your hand if you have additional
questions
on this uh in relation to ukraine
moses is your question about that i see
that your hand is up
if that's the case go ahead mosey
can we have mosey on the line
to your first question i mean your
announcements about the situation of the
border between poland and belarus i
think you started the discussion with
that
so can i continue with my question
yes you can
yes you can okay thank you very much you
mentioned in your announcement that
the commissioner made in contact with
international organizations and also the
international red cross
and then the question is of course when
the that commission assess that
humanitarian aid can be provided to the
stranded migrants at the board because i
think we're all seeing pictures from the
board and
and the time cut is worsening and then
it brings me to another question with a
link to yesterday's
press conference
about pushbacks about the suspicions
pushbacks by poland and we were told
that the commission cannot assess that
as long because they don't have enough
service they're not allowed to enter the
region at the same time we also know
that the commission is analyzing let's
say the changes in
polish you know lithuanian asylum
legislation
and the question is now let's say
and it's not possible that they might be
compatible with international law in new
zealand but they still they might also
allow poland to carry out pushbacks
and that's quite serious as we know that
poland doesn't recognize let's say the
primacy of a law
so what is a comment to that maybe it's
a question for audelberg
thank you very much
a wide
span of questions in relation to this
complex situation there
as an answer to the first leg of your
question um on the humanitarian
situation
as we have said repeatedly um we are
following this closely and we are ready
to do what we can to prevent
a humanitarian crisis from unfolding
and
we want to prevent further suffering for
the people trapped at the border as we
said we were happy to see that yesterday
iom and unhcr were granted access
to the place at the border where about 2
000 migrants
are trapped
and they could deliver yesterday some
items of first necessity we're also in
touch directly and
intensely with the red cross to see what
needs financially uh they have that we
can cover in order to provide uh further
support because again uh the well-being
of the people there and the protection
of the people there is one
is an important concern for us so we
will update you uh in real time when we
have more details and more developments
in relation to the humanitarian support
for the people at the border in relation
to your second question
on alleged pushbacks or rather the
implementation of legislation there
allow me to invite um adelbert to
provide you
our opposition but also allow me to
stress that it hasn't evolved so much
since yesterday when we already had that
discussion
hello thank you very much
for raising
this question again um we've as dana
said we've had this discussion yesterday
as well as day before yesterday
um and in fact it's also an uh an issue
that
uh commissioner yuanson addressed
numerous times
in in particular in front of the
european parliament and i would perhaps
just to refer you to all the comments
that have been made on this issue in any
case our assessment
of
the different laws that have been
adopted is ongoing we have been in
contact with the national authorities uh
in in this regard and when it comes to
the uh the implementation on the ground
we have also i believe said at this
point uh everything that we are able to
say uh right now and we continue to
follow the situation very closely
taking all the actions that donna
outlined at the beginning of
the midday
thank you very much are there any
additional questions for other bear on
the situation at the border
so please only raise your hand if you
have a question about that yes please go
ahead
khalid amid farooqly from geotelevision
news uh
can you tell us how many nationalities
among these 2000
people who are trapped at the border
thank you
thank you very much there is a very
difficult question for adelbert to
answer because of course we do not have
an overview of what is happening in
belarus but adalber how can we help
thank you khaled and indeed i think
you're putting your finger on one of the
very difficult aspects of the situation
we have just welcomed the fact that
there has been for the first time access
granted to international organizations
um to
to the people trapped at this border
other than that
we do not have uh have access to these
people so we are not in a position to
confirm who exactly they are we only
have uh second-hand information and and
and intelligence that comes to us from
from various sources including from our
member states but we would not be the
best uh the best source to confirm that
information so unfortunately the
information
accurate information as to who exactly
is there does not seem to be really
available and that underscores again
the
human the need to to address the
humanitarian
aspect of this situation created by the
location regime which is again why we
are working on all the different aspects
that i mentioned
thank you very much adelberg are there
any additional questions for adelberg on
the situation at the belarus border
samuel i think that you you want to
engage with us on that can we have
samuel on the line
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
if
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes but my question is not on
russell ukraine is on russia can i go on
or must i wait
um i think you can go i think you can go
okay thank you so
uh yesterday the russian general
prosecutor's office demanded the
liquidation of the world known
society a human rights society called
memorial
which has
among
among its activities has
identified thousands of foreign victims
of the stunning repressions
are you aware of this and if if so
would you commend that
thank you mom chill indeed we are not
only aware but we strongly deplored this
uh decision or this move by the russian
prosecutor
memorial is a renowned internationally
renowned and acknowledged and recognized
ngo uh providing very important work for
the civil society and the society in
russia that's why this is this is a
deplorable decision and this is just yet
another example of um how the state
authorities are shrinking the space for
civil society for the critical voices so
in addition to targeting journalists and
and political activists they are also
trying to target ngos and this is
something which uh is done for example
through the foreign agent law which we
called on russia repeatedly to repel
because it's uh contradicting
international obligations by russia so
uh we are just calling on russian
authorities to reverse these steps and
we see it as yet another example of
of ongoing restrictions or ongoing
efforts to restrict the space for
critical voices within the russian
society
thank you very much peter mom chill you
have a follow-up question go ahead
the step taken towards a memorial a
reason for a special alarm
meaning that
if this society is investigating the
starting terror so such
such an organization will be liquidated
isn't it a reason for a bigger alarm
well indeed uh as i said i mean we are
already armed enough by all the steps
that have been taken against uh ngos
again other against other ngos against
all the critical voices within the
russian society memorial of course is
probably the most known and also beyond
russian borders this uh organization or
this ngo is very important in the
protection of human rights and also in
elaborating the history and processing
the history of political repression in
russia so it's work it's very valuable
for the russian society for the russian
people to understand in what kind of
regime there have they have been living
and they are probably still living so
this is uh this is a source for alarm
and it needs to be seen in the context
of the ongoing systematic efforts which
have been there since many months by the
state authorities to misuse the state
powers and this uh this law foreign
agents law and also another law which is
uh the law on undesirable organizations
to really go after those who dare to
voice critical opinion question the
official narrative and uh and try to
enlighten the russian society about the
about the situation uh which which the
country has been living or is living
nowadays so uh in this indeed this is a
source of concern and i can only repeat
the call of the european union for on
the russian authorities to reverse the
steps and stop shrinking the space for
the civil society and for the critical
voices to have the exchanges which are
very healthy and very important for
every civilized european society
thank you peter mom chill i think you
have another follow-up
no
no no no no no so your hand was just up
very good uh please now keep your hand
up if you have additional questions for
peter on russia
so only questions on russia at this
stage
i don't see any
so then please
indicate your interest to ask additional
questions to peter on other topics yes
david
hello can you hear me we can go ahead we
can go okay um it's related to belarus
but it's um so we heard the german
foreign minister yesterday um
uh mentioning the possibility of further
sanctions on potash fertilizers
um and related to this i i don't know if
you're aware it's detailed but a lot of
the price of fertilizers comes from
uh natural gas prices
um
and then the second element of that is
obviously lukashenko's
threat to cut off gas supplies to europe
so this this would hit in two ways if it
ever came about
my question to you or to the commission
is uh
what planning is there at this moment in
in case this comes about in case it's
not just a threat but uh lukashenko
pulls it through
and then in terms of um
widening sanctions
uh that that your own officials in
august the the said that the um
eu sanctions on belarus fertilizers were
very limited
if they were to be white and this would
have an even greater effect on
fertilizer prices and agriculture so
what planning are you doing in the
eventuality that this comes about
thank you very much let me address some
of the last bits of your question before
giving the the floor to peter
[Music]
for a broad
[Music]
statement on sanctions so first of all
let us restate our position very clearly
we are not going to be intimidated by
any blackmail or threats
gas is a commodity and cannot be used as
a tool to blackmail or to achieve
leverage in any discussion this is our
very very very clear
position and i'm very happy that you
gave us the opportunity to state it here
again
secondly
on the other legs of the question allow
me to
uh on sanctions allow me to give the
question to peter
thank you there's
not more to add what we have been saying
uh since uh basically this
this issue came up the european union
currently the member states are working
on enlarging the scope of the sanctions
and to see if
further measures are necessary in order
to react to what lukashenko regime is
currently doing
so these discussions you know take in
the in the atmosphere of confidentiality
uh member states are discussing it uh
the decisions can be expected rather
soon so it's not really for me to
speculate what if and uh what what
sectors what commodities what people and
uh and etc would be would be targeted
but this is the part this is part of our
overall approach sanctions are not the
policy sanctions are a tool we are using
and applying sanctions as one of the
instruments along other uh instruments
we have at hand and other instruments
have been discussed here also very
thoroughly and that's the outreach with
the countries uh of origin and transit
when it comes to instrumentalization of
migration but also working with other
partners uh worldwide when it comes to
sanctioning for example the ongoing
repression against the russian
population because this is also
something that is being forgotten
currently that uh the primary reason for
the situation of today and the actions
of lukashenko regime is to cover up for
his ongoing repression of his own
citizens over 35 000 people in belarus
have been imprisoned or detained and
persecuted only because they dared to um
say their opinion that they don't like
this current regime and and mr
lukashenko there are over 800 political
prisoners in belarus the repression is
ongoing against civil society
independent media human rights activists
being intimidated uh detained or
sentenced uh in in trials behind closed
doors so he wants to cover up for this
and the european union together with
international partners are trying to
react to it with a set of activities and
tools sanctions are one of them
sanctions are currently under discussion
and it comes down to the member states
and their willingness ability to end
ability to reach consensus about the
scope and the content of the sanctions
we are which are which have been done
which are being under discussion or
which might come even afterwards after
the fifth expected round of the
sanctions
thank you very much i think that david
has a follow-up question so go ahead
is is this going through yeah um so
yeah my question wasn't about the eu
position or you know that we're not
going to bend to threats or all the
uh
actions um of the belarus regime it was
purely related to
the effects of any action that the eu
takes in in very crucial
fields i mean this is food we're talking
about at the end of the day and we're
also talking about eating
um at a crucial period where where
things are getting very cold in many
states so i was just wondering on this
this these points
um
what planning is the commission doing in
the eventuality that we we go to a
situation which is much tougher in terms
of sanctions uh sectoral sanctions
economic sanctions thank you very much
for relaunching it um so allow me to say
that the question of any cutting off of
gas supplies by belarus or by anyone
else is a highly hypothetical one so we
are not going to engage directly into
what might or might white
might not happen and what is the
thinking about that in minsk however on
a more general note uh what i can tell
you is about our
preparedness with regards to energy
and you've been truly following for for
several weeks or even months now the
discussions that we had
um about
energy supplies about prices of gas
prices of energy of
energy in general and of electricity and
you are perhaps aware of the reflections
that we have been carrying out
in-house
about how to
uh do everything uh uh possible uh to
make sure that europeans are not
affected by issues linked to gas supply
or by the prices of energy
this winter
and thereafter
allow me to say that a few weeks ago we
published a communication where
we state uh clearly the actions that we
take
the short term so to compensate uh
europeans for any hikes
in prices caused by the situation
with regards to supply we have also told
specifically how we carry out outreach
with regards to other suppliers of gas
than the ones that you
mention
in order to
secure and increase the supply of this
commodity
and we have also um explained how we go
about the other sources of energy which
are invaluable in our
energy
as a supply for instance renewables
because we have been
saying and i'm very happy to to say it
ago
the way ahead is really to
to grow
european-based renewable energy
sources which are clean which are stable
and whose price has been decreasing
constantly over the years so we have
announced a number of measures with a
short-term perspective to protect
europeans from any
such risks which would have an effect on
price
and we have also presented our thinking
and the measures that we will
take
in the medium term with relation to
strategic
reserves
or in relation to
um
to the energy market to enable uh the
the most
the best possible and the most adequate
functioning of the
energy market uh so that is uh amply
available to you if you wish and we can
provide even additional details um
after this with a briefing through our
energy spokesperson
yes please go ahead and allow me to add
one more sentence because i mean trying
to to take lukashenko's remarks at their
face value is basically contributing to
spreading his false narrative he tries
to basically or he continues in the
disinformation efforts which his regime
was doing already
on other issues like threatening the eu
this is not the first threat ukashenko
is doing so i mean speculating on what
might happen on what my uh what might
be the problem for the eu if he delivers
on his threats basically if he would
deliver on his threat he would harm
first of all below russian people he
would further harm the image of his
country and he would also harm the
supplier of the gas and i don't think
this is this is a game he wants to play
so bottom line is for the eu in our
approach to belarus to stop him from
doing what he is doing and to return
back to the normal civilized way of
behaving towards neighbors and
especially towards his own people
thank you are there any additional
questions for uh peter on belarus on
belarus
uh yes yuri
go ahead
uh do you hear me
we can hear you yes good
thank you very much uh yeah my question
is on belarus i don't know if it's for
you donna or for petr
so you indicated that uh there was an
outreach to different uh airlines and it
was clear that uh
that there was an outreach to turkish
authorities and to turkish airlines
because of what we heard today
can you elaborate about other airlines
and especially
whether any outreach to ire of law to
russian authorities and also if you have
any indications if aeroflot is bringing
any migrants to belarus or not thank you
very much thank you very much yuri for
this i will invite stefan to provide you
more details about our ongoing contacts
with airlines
hello good morning thank you very much
or good afternoon brother
um yes donna has made a quite extensive
statement on the work that has been
ongoing at the level of the vice
president skinner's commissioner valiant
and
their their respective teams
several contacts have been established
with a number of individual airlines
including
fly dubai turkish airlines royal air
mark air arabia emirates qatar airways
etihad
middle eastern airlines oman air iraqi
airways and egypt air these are the
airlines that have been contacted in the
context of
the
difficult
situation that we are all trying to
handle now and as donna said all these
airlines have strongly condemned any
form of
human trafficking and this has even led
to a few very concrete
actions already
this is what i can share at this stage
regarding the the different airlines
that have been contacted have been
involved in our talks thank you
thank you are there any additional
questions for
stefan on airlines
or for peter more broadly on the belarus
situation the external angle
that doesn't seem to be the case or
perhaps jean-pierre
champions
league
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes go ahead
it totally is different but um by the
30th of june
the commission was supposed to do a
review
of
high eye look
land use change feedstocks
palm is already considered high land
land use so it's you know contributing
to deforestation
soy is another feedstock which has been
mentioned it's very close to the
criteria laid down
um so this review was by the commission
was due by the 30th of june it's it's
not there now uh you know we're almost
at the end of the year i was wondering
would this review come out next week
when we have this deforestation
regulation or is this planned for some
other time and will soy uh be included
as high uh i look risk
thank you very much david for the agenda
and the all the elements of the packages
that will be on the agenda of the
college next week i will just simply
invite you to wait uh until monday
because as you know the the agendas of
what is the uh um what is being
discussed by the college of
commissioners is being confirmed mondays
when the chef of cabinet of
commissioners uh meet and when they uh
when the last decisions are made
considering what is ripe for discussion
and for adoption um
by uh the commission uh but i also uh
understand from vivian that what you are
referred to is a separate uh report uh
under the lulucf
directive so
unless vivian has additional elements to
uh to bring on the state at this point i
will tell you that you will check about
the date of release of
this report but it's separate from what
the college will um will discuss and
adopt next week
i hope this helps
do you have a follow-up question david
yeah it's not about the lululu cf it's
um it's a 2009 delegated
delegated regulation
um but it is quite an important subject
um it concerns deforestation but the
energy use of it so it's separate from
what's coming out on the agenda
um i mean my question is it's more about
better regulation really because um you
know
the commission committed to to doing
this review by the
30th of june
uh this year it's not there i understand
that you are really really busy with the
fifa 55 package but could you explain
why it's not there and
when will it come
thank you very much so uh i think now um
it's clear what you are asking about and
i believe that this is something that
tim could provide an answer from again
from glasgow so tim are you connected
did you catch the question and are you
ready to provide any details about this
uh i'm i i'm connected and i caught the
question um but i don't have specific
details on the timing and the procedure
i mean i think what i would just say in
general terms as as always is that you
know we we want to do a very thorough
process and make sure that the work is
done comprehensively
and that all issues are addressed
and
as soon as we are able to present
something we of course will do so and
that view that will look into it and and
come back to you and see if there is any
precision on timing
okay thank you very much tim and you
will get back to daffy bilaterally i
will now to
i will invite you to indicate your
interest in asking additional
questions we have been mixing up
subjects here on on stage
stemming from
energy linked to belarus to other
aspects of energy and i know that
colleagues still have additional
questions about the previous subjects so
yes
allow me to give the floor to lorenzo
my question
concerns a decision by the
lorenzo i'm afraid to say the sound is
not very good so could you start uh from
the beginning again
okay
can you hear me better no it's better
thank you go ahead okay
i hope this question has not been asked
yesterday because i couldn't follow
yesterday this is about the concessions
the state concessions for beaches
uh in italy there was a decision by the
conserta the italian
council of state and and this this
according to this decision
actually
the automatic
extension of the concessions that had
been given
for a very long period in 2035
is now
as now to be stopped in 2023
december 2023
so since this is a
an issue that has
raised a lot of interest and the
commission is involved in this because
there is a sentence of the course of
justice
uh can you tell us what you think about
this uh this decision and if this is a
satisfactory way out uh in the situation
uh we literally about this thank you
sonia
main thanks for your question lorenzo
indeed the commission as you know is
following this case very closely and we
welcome the decision of the highest
administrative court of italy which
confirms the position of the commission
and also the
judgment the latest judgment of the
court of justice so the italian
authorities need to proceed with the
reform of the system and they need to
award the beach concession contracts in
a transparent and non-discriminatory way
and it's extremely important because the
tourism sector including the beach
concessions
and the beach resorts in italy have
suffered a lot during the covet crisis
and this sector has been hit very hard
so the sector needs to be modernized in
its innovation competitiveness and
growth so we believe that through the
concession contract awards in a
transparent and objective way this
sector will be helped also to
reboost and recover financially from the
crisis so we prompt the italian
authorities to follow very swiftly the
decision of the highest administrative
court and to start
awarding the concession contracts for
the period following 2023
thank you very much sonia
are there any additional questions on
the subject
for sonia on concessions
or are there any additional questions
for sonia for the other
files that she follows
that's not the case so thank you sonia
are there any other questions for us
today
yes david you've been waiting for a
while go ahead
we mercy um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
um
[Music]
methodology
[Music]
m
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes go ahead
thank you um a fishing question for
vivian uh
we've had kind of a month now of
intensive negotiations or discussions
between
britain the eu and france i'm just
wondering if you could give us any
update on how these are going
um whether we've we've made any progress
have we have britain been able to
license any more vessels that you can
announce
um that's basically it thank you
thank you very much and yeah let's see
what
updates vivian can provide on fish
thank you very much joe for this
opportunity to give you the update after
a week of not touching on the subject
well the thing is that the talks are
still ongoing and on the european side
we are really working uh
hard in making sure that our fishermen
and women get those licenses that they
have the right to get according to the
to the agreements that we have in place
and i don't have any more details to
share with you today just that we've had
the week where we've had the talks we
see that they are
necessary to bring in information that
is needed on both sides and we continue
with those thank you
thank you vivian
are there any additional questions for
vivian on fisher fishery related matters
i don't see any other questions for
vivian on other measures that she covers
not the case either so thank you vivian
and let me ask you invite you once more
to raise your hand if you have other
questions for us today and i see that
catalin is interested to open another
subject so go ahead cataline
yes thank you very much donna this is a
question about the rule of law
conditionality mechanism
can you confirm that the commission has
finalized uh two letters to hungary and
to poland in formal letters
asking clarifications
and the president of the commission has
blocked
sending these letters to to relevant
governments
thank you
thank you very much catalin what i can
clearly say is that work is ongoing uh
in the european commission across the
consent services on the matter of the
rule of law mechanism and balance can
give you a further update on where we
stand
indeed my confirmation will be of
similar nature the work is very much
ongoing on this file the regulation came
into force in the first of january since
then we've been working very hard to
build up
potential
cases under this regulation and i should
add that
under article 6 paragraph 4 of the
regulation the commission has the
opportunity to request information from
the member states concern whether it be
after the so-called formal launch of the
procedure or before so when um
we feel the need to reach out to a
member state for additional information
we will certainly not hesitate to do so
thank you very much and i recall you
that the the president also said in
their social speech that
we are working on this and we will be
sending uh letters um
rapidly and we are at that stage
i see that david has his hand up david
would you want to ask a question about
this matter or is it
different
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are there any other questions for us
today
i don't see any so thank you very much
have a great weekend and see you next
week
you